Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Arrow Mid Season Finale
video.
We got everything this week.
We have Bondage, we have awesome villains,
we have other people wearing Oliver's Costume.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet.
Don't you just love how they kinda did a twist
on what they did with the Oliver Queen death
last season and let's be honest raise your
hand who thinks the Felicity is dead right
now or she is dying honestly I don't think
that the show's going to kill off such a big
character this early in the season whenever
they flash forward to that grave at the beginning
of the season they were flashing forward six
months that puts it at the full season finale
episode 23 so were not even halfway to whoever
ends up in that grave dying so just based
on his past episode definitely not going to
be Felicity that doesn't mean that she's not
gonna die at some point that just means that
this episode is not indicating who setting
up in the grave just a quick reminder that
the reverse flash ring giveaway is still going
on all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video real simple
so here we go top five WTF number five Damien
Darhk Strafes Oliver's cleaning of the bay
with a bunch of schoolchildren all her guest
the save a mini Felicity almost in the exact
same way that he saves Felicity at the beginning
of season two I think it was I think that
time he was swinging on a vibrant like he
tackles Felicity to save her from the strap
tackles mini Felicity who is also pretty adorable
her self to I'm sure some day that little
girls going to have some super duper crush
on Mayor Oliver Queen that's the guy that
saved me and that wasn't even as green arrow
Oliver Queen was doing this in public in the
light of day that's kind of a big thing this
season Oliver stepping out into the light
I mean it's the holidays right now so they're
doing holiday lighting's but you know thematically
stepping out into the light because Damien
Darhk is part of the darkness flash and arrow's
pun game has been really strong this week
that's actually a game to play after you watch
the episode one time go back and watch it
again and see if you can spot all of the puns
from flash and arrow this week onto my number
four WTF though Diggle versus his brother
he's trying so hard to help his brother Andy
but Andy just is not having it you don't know
the real me I mean right now I don't think
we really have a good sense for what's going
on in Andy's head he's not brainwashed anymore
is not on the chemicals the Damien Darhk hands
out the people and maybe he's fully drunken
the Kool-Aid so you can actually add him to
the list of people that might end up in that
grave I mean I think Diggle or Clinton would
be a bigger WTF because it be like a core
team arrow person but anytime would also be
really emotional for team arrow just because
you're so close to Diggle on my number three
WTF all of like the relationship comedy so
when one lane you have Oliver and Felicity
like that the whole comedy about the ring
Felicity finding it her mom freaking out than
in the other lane you have Felicity's mom
and Quentin which is actually way funnier
for me seriously don't tell Laurel she doesn't
know yet Felicity just throwing up in her
mouth but the whole deal with Felicity in
the ring with already made it very easy to
follow Felicity just doesn't want Oliver to
take the choice of choosing to marry him away
from her but Alber has this big deal where
he tries to protect everyone so he takes a
lot of choice away from people like he chooses
for them she made the joke last week that
Oliver was back in secret keeping mode that
was about his secrets on which he still hasn't
told this version of Felicity in this timeline
yet but Felicity just like seriously if you
would've asked I would've said yes I chose
this life I get to choose who protects me
it's the don't treat me like a damsel in distress
speech the problem with that is that even
though she's gung ho about this there are
consequences it's easy to say don't protect
me I can take care of myself until you get
bit by a shark like flashback Oliver on my
number two WTF Merlyn to the rescue he was
on fire this week seriously this layer is
easier to break into the in your last one
that he just he appears out of nowhere he's
kind of a magical character even though he's
not using magic and I love the fact that they
let him where the green arrow costume is kind
of a running thing on arrow with other people
getting to where Oliver's costume Roy's word
Oliver's costume Diggle's worn Oliver's costume
I'd say they let the canary and feel where
the costume but I think that they're too short
using the other people that we are Oliver's
costume kind of resemble him physically like
they're almost the exact same size that's
why Diggle could do it that's why Merlyn can
do it is about the same size but there was
a brief moment when he was fighting Damien
Darhk that I was like who may be Merlyn's
going to be the one that dies that John Barrowman
is an amazing actor so I'd I think would really
suck if the show lost them but he did explain
this episode like I mean he's still a big
part of this league of assassins storyline
the reason the he didn't use them is because
he doesn't want open war between the league
and I because hive is a way bigger organization
than they let on during arrow episode is bad
asses the league of assassins are you can't
blame Merlyn for wine to keep them out of
it but he does want to protect the DSO course
she's going to throw himself in what about
the Genesis project though Damien Darhk, does
this demonstration it just seems like knockout
gas what I think it's going to be is like
a low level version of what he's giving to
the ghosts like turn everyone into worker
bees as in hive so bad news is probably has
absolutely nothing to do with new Genesis
or apocalypse or new gods I know we thought
this might be a mother box a couple episodes
ago probably not here is probably going a
little bit more realistic albeit with some
magic thrown in the the funny thing about
this is as it Damien Darhk's plan seems that
he has Apsley nothing to do with magic this
is hives plan some of the other members of
hive think of him is like a charlatan they
actually said that in an earlier episodes
with them like the rest of hive doesn't really
know what's going on with Damien Darhk's magic
or course on my number one WTF what are you
gonna do about Oliver queen cut to limo assassination
attempt just the way they cut the episode
from scene to scene like the one from the
lighting ceremony to Damien Darhk back to
Oliver in the limo with Felicity you knew
exactly what was going to happen question
is though is what can happen to Felicity now
obviously always going to be passed Felicity
in the teaser for the next episode is being
willed in the critical-care so I definitely
don't think she's going to die but I think
it's intended to push Oliver in a darker direction
like how you how dare you come after the person
that I love in this way how dare you try to
kill us.
My question for you guys let me know in the
comments what you think is going to happen
with Damien Darhk's plan do you think he's
just going to try and disseminate this biological
agent just you to take over the entire city
it seems that they're just contained in this
one city for now Star city but what about
Oliver what you think that Oliver is going
to do to retaliate I know there is a whole
bunch of other stuff that they've announced
for the second half of the season the bringing
Felicity's father on they've already announced
that he's going to be the calculator the episode
that he is coming in will also be the episode
that Colton comes back for the tease that
they released is that the calculator is using
Roy to enact is blackmailing Roy into committing
crimes for them so team arrow I besought the
save Roy takedown calculator the actor that
they cast is one of the dads from Everwood
if you haven't seen that show in a long time
it was Greg Berlanti is like the first big
TV show we see now you have this giant Titan
of TV the way way back he had a TV show with
star Lord and agent 13 sauna all feel like
this is a good episode it was a very different
type of episode like the tone was very different
from the flash or even agent to shield her
some of the other midseason finale's from
the comic book TV shows I feel like it was
a good episode for people that really hate
Felicity's character because you like all
yeah yeah they definitely took her down or
if you're really into the relationship comedy
stuff because there was a lot of that in this
episode but had to say Neal McDonough the
actor who plays Damien Darhk is doing an amazing
job way better as a big bad Vince zoom is
right now technically zoom is the big bad
of the flash even though Harrison wells seems
like an antagonist is another good question
let me know in the comments who do you think
has like the best villain performance so far
Neal McDonough know playing arrow or Tony
Todd playing the zoom character because you
like Zoom does have more power like he's more
powerful he is the speed you special abilities
that may or may not be more powerful and Damien
Darhk's magic we really don't have any idea
that there's no basis for comparison on that
I feel like they're very different types of
Dawn so it's kind of apples and origins I
feel like they're both amazingly Tony Todd
is amazing as the voices of Zoom, just completely
terrifying still so many question marks and
Neil McDonough just wipes the floor with all
the other actors whenever you share scenes
with them great holiday episode though everybody
be sure to high-five Quentin on your way out
for getting all some Thursday how long has
it been since he's been on a date maybe after
he and River song broke up actually got a
shout out during the flash episode this of
the Laurel was in Central city visiting her
mother so was can happen is is there a couple
trailers for the rest of the season all these
try to get a flash or not I don't know if
I'll have time to do and arrow 12 but I'll
definitely try to do and arrow videos sometime
later this week is a new Doctor strange video
that I have there's new Star Wars and there's
new Captain America Civil War video so I'll
try to get that out as fast as possible white
as way for my next video to post click here
for last night's episode of the flash Yet
my Batman v Superman trailer videos thank
you so much watching everybody high five and
I'll see you tonight!